네, 안녕하세요. 오늘은 여러분들한테
도움이 될 만한 기사를 좀 준비를
했습니다. 그래서 그 기사를 좀
보면서 팩트는 팩트대로 그리고 이제
제 의견을 좀 곁드리는 그런 시간을
좀 가질 건데 어, 우선 기사를 좀
보면은 지난해 1월부터 11월까지
상업용 빌딩 거래 건수가 5.2%
감소했다라는 내용이 있는데 이건 일단
팩트가 맞습니다. 그리고 이제 기사
내용을 좀 자세하게 살펴보면은 중소형
빌딩 규모, 그러니까 이제 보통은
50억 미만의 꼬마 빌딩 [음악]
규모의 거래 건수가 좀 많이
줄어들었다라는 내용으로 좀 보시면 될
거 같아요. 네. 그리고 기사 내용
중에 21년 거래 건수와 비교하면
거의 반토막 수준이다라는 내용이
있는데 이것도 팩트가 맞습니다. 근데
아셔야 될게 21년도의 기준 금리는
0.5%에서 5%에서 한 1%
사이였어요. 그래서 기준 [음악]
금리가 진짜 말도 안 되게
낮았습니다. 그래서 그때 빌산남
중개법인에서 거의 한 1조 정도
중계를 했어요. 그리고 담보 대출
금리가 2% 때 진짜 워낙 많이
나오고 1% [음악] 대도
나왔습니다. 그래서 웬만한 빌딩이
어느 정도 수익률만 나오면 진짜 대출
금리보다 훨씬 잘 나왔거든요. 그래서
레버리지 수익률이 되게 높았습니다.
네. 그래서 그때 시장은 진짜 웬만한
건물들 가격이 다 올랐어요. 그리고
그때 당시에는 그래도 [음악] 임대
시장이 괜찮았기 때문에 그때보다는
거래 건수가 좀 많이 줄어들었어요.
[음악] 요즘에는 기준 금리도 좀
오르고 그리고 공실도 되게 높아지다
보니까 그때와 비교해서는 거래 건수가
좀 많이 줄었습니다. 그때는 사실
진짜 말도 안 되는 시장이었습니다.
네. 그리고 금리 인상으로 인해서
거래 건수가 좀 줄었다라고 하는데
사실 [음악] 2024년도의 기준
금리 보면은 3.5%였어요. 근데
이제 작년 같은 경우에는 뭐 최저한
2.5%까지 좀 내려왔습니다. 그래서
오히려 금리가 내려왔는데도 [음악]
불구하고 거래 건수가 조금 줄었어요.
네. 근데 그 이유 중에 가장 큰게
저는 공실이라고 생각을 합니다.
그래서 자영업자분들이 계속 안
좋아지면서 어 임대가 [음악] 진짜
잘 안 돼요. 그래서 일반
투자자분들이 예전에는 그래도 임대가
들어오긴 했는데 [음악] 임대가 계속
안 들어오기 시작하면서 되게
보수적으로 좀 많이 바뀌었습니다.
어떻게 운영이 가능할지 어떻게 임대가
가능할지를 되게 세세하게 보기
시작했어요. [음악] 네. 기사에서
좀 잘못 나온게 이제 금리가 상승해서
그렇다. 그게 아니라 금리가
내려가는데도 불구하고 임대 시장이 좀
좋지 않아서 어 거래 건수가 좀
줄어들지 않았나 어 이렇게 생각을
합니다. 그리고요 기사를 보면은 그
아파트랑 그다음 이제 빌딩 시장을
같이 비교하는게 있는데 저는 약간
성격이 좀 다르다라고 보거든요.
아파트나 이런 주거는 어찌 됐든
거주를 해야 되니까 무조건 사야 되는
자산 중에 하나입니다. 근데 빌딩은
사실 사도 그만 안 사도 그만이에요.
그래서 오히려 저는 빌딩과 비교해야
될게 예를 들어서 뭐 배당을 주는
주식 아니면 [음악] 예금 예를
들어서 뭐 예금 금리가 빌딩이
수익률보다 더 높다라고 하면 사실
예금을 투자하잖아요. 그것처럼 이렇게
월 수입을 주는 예금이나 이런 주식
같은 거와 비교해야 되지 않나 그렇게
생각을 [음악] 합니다. 근데 빌딩의
추가적인 장점은 직접 사용할 수도
있고 어찌됐든 현물이 있기 때문에
그런 걸 선호하시는 분들이 빌딩을
사는 거 같아요. 그리고 아파트가
작년 1월부터 11월까지는 거래량이
좀 많이 늘긴 했는데 근데 10월
15일 부동산 대책 이후에는 아마
거래 건수가 좀 줄었을 거예요. 네.
근데 그 통계가 아직 정확하게 좀
많이 나와 있지 않습니다. 그래서
올해 뭐 1월부터 올해 전체를 좀
통계를 좀 유심히 보시는게 중요한 거
같아요. 작년 이제 대출 [음악]
규제라든지 이런 토지 거래 허가
때문에 어 작년 10월 이후에 거래
건수는 좀 많이 줄었을 것으로 좀
예상이 됩니다. [음악] 그리고 좀
전체적인 흐름을 봤을 때 주식 요즘에
되게 좋잖아요. 시장이 주식하시는
분들이 어찌됐든 올해는 주식 시장을
좋다라고 많이 예상을 하시더라고요.
그래서 뭐 올해까지는 뭐 주식을 계속
가지고 있을 수 있지만 어느 시점이
되면 이거를 팔고 좋은 집을 샀다가
그리고 나중에 이제 뭐 [음악] 빌딩
시장까지 흘러 들어오는 그런 시기가
좀 오지 않을까 그렇게 예상을
합니다. 네. 그래서 제가 좀
전체적으로 좀 정리를 해 보면 일단은
24년도와 비교해서는 25년도에 거래
건수가 준 거는 팩트가 [음악]
맞습니다. 근데 뭐 금리가 올라서
거래 건수가 준게 아니라 금리가
오히려 내려가긴 했지만 인대 시장이
좋지 않아서 그리고 개인 투자자분들이
[음악]
좀이 공실이라든지 이렇게 되게 좀
신중하게 투자하기 시작했거든요.
그래서 좀 확실한 곳, 확실한 지역에
확실한 빌딩만 거래가 되기
시작했습니다. 그리고 아파트랑 빌딩
시장은 저는 개인적으로 좀 다르게
봐야 된다라고 생각이 들고 아파트는
무조건 사야 되는 것 중에 하나고
의식주 중에 하나잖아요. 근데 빌딩은
사실 사도 그만 안 사도 그만이기
때문에 오히려 예금이나 이런 배당을
주는 주식 아니면 채권이라든지 이런
거랑 비교를 해야 됩니다. 그래서
그런 금리를 좀 유심히 봐야 되는
부분이 있고 만약에 뭐 배당을 주는
주식 그 금액이 더 크다라고 하면
오히려 그쪽으로 더 빠져나가거든요.
그래서 그 아파트랑 빌딩이랑은 조금
다른 구조로 [음악] 좀 봐야 되지
않나 어 이렇게 생각을 합니다.네
그래서 오늘 제가 뉴스를 좀
준비했는데 어 좀 도움이 되셨으면
좋겠고 그리고 3월에는 [음악]
저희가 이제 또 스터디를 해요.
그래서 37기까지 했었고 진짜 10년
동안 스터디를 했는데 정말 여러분들
빌딩 [음악] 살 계획이라고 하면이
강의 무조건 들어야 됩니다. 저희가
37기 동안 정말 빌딩 강의를 하면서
수정 보안을 굉장히 많이 했거든요.
그래서 수강생분들한테 진짜 필요한게
뭔지 진짜 말로만 하는게 아니라 실제
사례를 많이 준비를 했고 그리고 제가
유튜브에서 실패 사례를 말씀을 못
드려요. 실패 사례 말씀 못 드리는데
저희가 [음악] 스터디에서는 정말
실패 사례도 낫게 좀 설명을
드립니다. 그래서 정말 도움이 될
만한 내용들로만 준비를 했으니까
여러분들이 빌딩 투자하신다 그러면이
스터디 꼭 들으셨으면 좋겠습니다.
그래서 제가 스터디 내용은 그
설명란에 써 놓을테니까 여기 타고
들어오시면은 [음악] 자세하게 보실
수 있으니까 참고하시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.